the universe
rather beautiful isn't it
it's quite literally got everything from
the very big to the very small
sure there are some less than savory
elements in there but on the whole
scholars agree that its existence is
probably a good thing
such a good thing that an entire field
of scientific endeavor is devoted to its
study
this is known as cosmology
cosmologists look at what's out there in
space and piece together the tale of how
our universe evolved what it's doing now
what it's going to be doing and how it
all began in the first place it was
edwin hubble who first noticed that our
universe is expanding by noting that
galaxies seem to be flying further and
further apart
this implied that everything should have
started with the monumental explosion of
an infinitely hot infinitely small point
this idea was jokingly referred to at
the time as the big bang
but as the evidence piled up the notion
and the name
actually stuck we know that after the
big bang the universe cooled down to
form the stars and galaxies that we see
today
cosmologists have plenty of ideas about
how this happened
but we can also probe the origins of the
universe by recreating the hot dense
conditions that existed at the beginning
of time in the laboratory
this is done by particle physicists
over the past century particle
physicists have been studying matter and
forces at higher and higher energies
firstly with cosmic rays and then with
particle accelerators machines that
smash together subatomic particles at
great energies the greater the energy of
the accelerator the further back in time
they can effectively peak today things
are largely made up of atoms but
hundreds of seconds after the big bang
it was too hot for electrons to join
atomic nuclei to make atoms instead the
universe consisted of a swirling sea of
subatomic matter
a few seconds after the big bang it was
hotter still hot enough to overpower the
forces that usually hold protons and
neutrons together in atomic nuclei
further back microseconds after the big
bang and the protons and neutrons were
only just beginning to form from quarks
one of the fundamental building blocks
of the standard model of particle
physics
further back still and the energy was
too great even for the quarks to stick
together physicists hope that by going
to even greater energies they can see
back to a time when all the forces were
one and the same which would make
understanding the origins of the
universe a lot easier
to do that they'll not only need to
build bigger colliders but also work
hard to combine our knowledge of the
very very big
with the very very small and share these
fascinating insights with each other and
with well you
and that's how it should be because
after all when it comes to our universe
we're all in this one together
you